ganz herzlichen Dank für die Vorstellung
ich freue mich heute hier zu sein das
erste Mal in ihrer Runde zu sein und
über eines meiner herzensthemen reden zu
dürfen die Hochschule als Resonanzraum
und ich habe gerade gedacht heute morgen
erlebe ich das genauso also bei mir ist
schon ganz viel in Resonanz gekommen an
diesem Vormittag insofern ganz
herzlichen Dank für alle Impulse und
davon wünsche ich mir mehr an unseren
Hochschulen ich habe meine Kernthese zu
Beginn mitgebracht es braucht mehr
Resonanz und Lebendigkeit in unseren
vorlesungsseminaren
damit
grenzüberschreitende Lehre gelingt
ja wie kann das aussehen wie kann die
Hochschule mehr zum Resonanzraum werden
das möchte ich heute mit ihnen in vier
Schritten
erkunden wir starten mit einer
persönlichen
mini-resonanz Erkundungen dann möchte
ich Ihnen einige Kerngedanken der
resonanzpädagogik vorstellen das ist ein
Konzept was nicht persönlich total
begeistert hat eben weil es mir eine
Sprache gegeben hat eigentlich um meine
besten und meine schlechtesten
Erfahrungen in der Lehre noch mal neu zu
beschreiben und zu verstehen
ich möchte einige wenige Aussagen von
Studierenden aus unserer Hochschule
ihnen noch zeigen wie beschreiben denn
diese Professorinnen und Professoren die
bei ihnen etwas in Resonanz gebracht
haben und abschließend möchte ich Ihnen
zwei kleine gut Practice Beispiele aus
meiner Lehrtätigkeit vorstellen wie ich
versuche Resonanz Erfahrungen zu fördern
zu Beginn möchte ich Sie einladen mit
mir auf Resonanz Erkundung zu gehen ist
so eine kleine wertschätzende Erkundung
das mache ich übrigens sehr gerne in
mein Seminaren oder Vorlesungen oder
auch in Meetings mit so einer
wertschätzenden Erkundung zu starten in
unserem Fall jetzt zurückzudenken ich
würde Sie einladen gehen Sie doch mal
zurück zu den Zeiten ihre Studiums an
welchen Dozierenden erinnern Sie sich
denn noch gerne zurück
was war Ihre beste Veranstaltung wer hat
bei Ihnen einen bleibenden Eindruck
hinterlassen ich möchte Ihnen kurz
vorstellen wer das bei mir war Professor
Eugen Bus
Soziologie Professor an der Universität
Hohenheim er hat mich sehr geprägt er
hat für seine Themen begeistern können
und er hat mich immer wieder persönlich
herausgefordert nämlich dass ich Themen
nicht nur mir aneigne und ich sag mal
nach erzähle sondern dass ich mich
wirklich auf Themen einlasse und Ihnen
eine persönliche Bedeutung gebe mein
erstes Seminar Wirtschaftssoziologie im
Hauptstudium da denke ich noch gern dran
zurück es ging ums Thema Wertewandel und
um die fragen wie man diesen untersuchen
kann er stellte ein Konzept vor anhand
von lesebuchgeschichten für Kinder
Rückschlüsse auf die Werte zu schließen
und sogar darauf wohin sich diese
Gesellschaft entwickeln wird
und meine allererste Seminararbeit
bestand dann darin schulbuchgeschichten
von Kindern auf ihren Werte gehalten zu
analysieren und sie können sich
vorstellen einige Jahre später ich habe
zwei teenagersöhne habe ich dann auch
die Lesebücher der Jungs in der
Grundschule mit ganz anderen Augen
gelesen also das ist mir ein bleibendes
Erlebnis er hat es geschafft mich für
Themen zu faszinieren da denke ich bis
heute noch gerne daran zurück was sind
ihre besten Beispiele vorher wurde schon
der Mathelehrer genannt der prägen die
Spuren hinterlassen hat am liebsten
würde ich mich jetzt direkt mit Ihnen
darüber austauschen das geht heute nicht
aber ich hoffe dass wir vielleicht die
ein oder anderen Beispiele nachher auch
noch in der Diskussion miteinander
besprechen können
ich würde Sie bitten für heute dass sie
ihren prägenden Dozenten vielleicht
einfach mal im Hinterkopf behalten wenn
ich Ihnen nun einige Kerngedanken der
resonanzpädagogik vorstelle
ja die
resonanzpädagogik ist eine Art der
Pädagogik die Resonanz in den
Mittelpunkt stellt und nicht Kompetenz
Resonanz wird sozusagen als Vorbedingung
angesehen damit Lehre damit lernen
gelingen kann die resonanzpädagogik baut
auf dem resonanzkonzept des deutschen
Soziologen Hartmut Rosa auf und wurde
dann von Hans Jens belljahn
weiterentwickelt aber was meint Resonanz
eigentlich das Wort kam jetzt schon so
oft vor mit Resonanz ist eine bestimmte
beziehungs- oder interaktionsqualität
gemeint das kann zwischen Menschen sein
aber auch zwischen einem Mensch und der
Welt an sich oder zwischen einer Person
und einem Thema zum Beispiel einer
Vorlesung und Resonanz ist immer von
vier Kennzeichen
begleitet nämlich es gibt immer einen
Moment in der Berührung also ein Thema
berührt mich spricht mich an bewegt mich
zweitens der Aspekt der
Selbstwirksamkeit dann klinke ich mich
sozusagen aktiv ein auf diesen Moment
der Berührung und antworte oder reagiere
darauf in meinem Fall war das ich habe
die lesebuchgeschichten analysiert ich
habe mit meinem Dozent und mit
Kommilitonen darüber diskutiert
dabei habe ich mich verändert
Transformation ist der dritte der dritte
Aspekt ich habe die Welt danach mit
anderen Augen gesehen
der vierte Aspekt Unverfügbarkeit
Resonanz kann man nicht machen und
managen sie ist unverfügbar
Hartmut Rosa beschreibt jetzt gelingende
Lehre als resonanzgeschehen also das
wäre jetzt so zu sagen der Idealfall
dass ich in der Lehre oder auch in der
Schulklasse in der Schule Resonanz
ereignet und das kann man mit einem
sogenannten resonanzdreieck darstellen
das resonanzdreieck hat den Anlehnung an
das didaktische Dreieck drei Pole da
gibt es die Dozierenden die Studierenden
und das Thema
diese drei Pole stehen aber nicht
unverbunden miteinander sondern
dazwischen gibt es sogenannte
resonanzachsen da passiert etwas da ist
eine Beziehung da da vibriert es im
Idealfall das kann auf der sozialen
Ebene hier links passieren zwischen
Menschen oder auf der sachlichen Ebene
zwischen Menschen und einem Thema
und die Kernaussage dieses Resonanz
Dreiecks ist
gelingende Lehre hängt sowohl von der
Qualität dazwischen menschlichen
Beziehung als auch von der Beziehung zum
Lernstoff oder zum Lehrstoff ab nur wenn
alle Achsen Resonanz sind also wenn
überall ein Wechselspiel da ist dann
kann ein Resonanzraum entstehen
sozusagen in der Mitte ein Ort an dem
sich Resonanz Erfahrung ereignen und ich
habe vorher schon gehört sie kennen das
selber aus der Lehre dann ist
Lebendigkeit und Energie im Raum dann
sind alle beteiligt
was ereignet sich da genau ich habe es
einfach noch mal hier in ein paar Kästen
gepackt die Dozierenden die sehen und
erreichen ihre Studierenden sie können
Begeisterung vermitteln aber sie sind
auch ihrerseits offen und lassen sich
begeistern oder lassen sich ihrerseits
wieder berühren
Studierende fühlen sich dann
wahrgenommen und wertgeschätzt sie
können sich öffnen sie lassen sich
begeistern bringen sich auch aktiv ein
und beide Studierende und Dozierende
haben eine connection zum Thema es
scheint bedeutungsvoll es hat etwas zu
sagen
so habe ich dieses Seminar bei Professor
Buss erlebt er und wir als Studierenden
wir haben uns eigentlich gegenseitig
motiviert und inspiriert und das ist für
mich ein Beispiel für gelingende
grenzüberschreitende Lehre dann findet
so ein lebendiges Wechselspiel aller
Beteiligten Stadt und es fordert
natürlich auch von allen Beteiligten
dass sie ein Stück weit über ihre
Grenzen gehen auch dazu haben wir vorher
schon mal was gehört bleibe ich eher in
einem distanzmodus oder mache ich mich
nahbar lasse ich mich auf andere
Menschen oder auch auf das Thema ein für
den Dutzend könnte das heißen dass er
oder sie die Agenda noch mal umstrickt
je nachdem wie die Studierenden ihre
Interessen haben für die Studierenden
könnte es heißen dass sie ihre
Komfortzone verlassen sich trauen Fragen
zu stellen zum Beispiel
und ich spannende finde ich wenn dieses
Wechselspiel so passiert dann entsteht
etwas Neues gemeinsames vielleicht
könnte man sagen diese Gemeinschaft von
lernen wie sie es vorher aus der
thematisiert haben dann gleich keine
Vorlesung der anderen selbst wenn es die
gleichen Themen sind
ja aus meiner Erfahrung sind es ist es
noch nicht der Regelfall dass das so
passiert das sind vielleicht ein paar
Sternstunden
wenn es nicht so ist dann könnte man
sagen es bleibt stumm im Seminarraum ich
habe hier mein sogenanntes stummes
Dreieck mitgebracht
sie sehen hier sind die Resonanz Achsen
unterbrochen man hat sich nichts zu
sagen und erreicht sich nicht dann kann
Lehre zu einer ziemlich leblosen
Geschichte werden und wahrscheinlich hat
jeder von ihnen auch das schon erlebt
wie kommen wir jetzt vom stummendreieck
zum resonanzdreieck wie viele andere
auch betont hat mit rosa hier die
Schlüsselrolle der leerenden
deshalb stehen die auch oben an der
Spitze des resonanzdreiecks weil sie
haben die Resonanz Verantwortung oder
ich müsste sagen wir haben die Resonanz
Verantwortung als Lehrende haben wir die
Verantwortung
resonanzprozesse zu initiieren und zwar
in zweierlei Richtungen einmal wieder in
Richtung auf der Beziehungsebene und
auch auf der Ebene der Stoffvermittlung
wir Dozierenden sollten idealerweise in
vorderleistung gehen was heißt das ganz
praktisch auf der Beziehungsebene ich
versuche meinen Studierenden mit einem
echten Interesse entgegenzutreten und
mit Wertschätzung dazu mache ich den
ersten Schritt rosa verwendet hier das
Bild der taktgeberin oder der Dirigenten
ich versuche sozusagen durch meinen
taktvolles Verhalten eine besondere
Atmosphäre eine vertrauensvolle
Atmosphäre eine nahbare Atmosphäre zu
schaffen die dann überhaupt auch erst
die Voraussetzung ist dass ich
Studierende öffnen können und genauso
auf der Ebene der Stoffvermittlung muss
ich in Vorleistung gehen das heißt ich
muss erstmal Energie und Begeisterung
vor investieren hier verwendet Hartmut
Rosa das Bild von der Stimmgabel ich bin
sozusagen als Dozentin sowohl erste
Stimmgabel die den Ton angibt als auch
wieder zweite Stimmgabel die offen ist
neugierig erwartungsvoll was denn von
meinen Studierenden zurückkommt
ich möchte Ihnen hier ein Zitat von
Hartmut Rosa vorstellen der Lehrer
erweist sich dabei als eine doppelte
Stimmgabel als erste Stimmgabel regt er
durch seine eigene Begeisterung die
Klasse zu mitschwingen an als zweite
Stimmgabel lässt er sich von den
Interessen seiner Schüler in Schwingung
versetzen
und für den Dozierenden heißt es es ist
natürlich auch ein Risiko auch davon
haben wir vorher schon mal gehört ich
weiß nämlich nicht ob das
resonanzangebot was ich gebe ob das dann
auch angenommen wird
ja Sie können vielleicht noch mal in
ihren prägenden Dozierenden denken ob
sie den vielleicht als Taktgeber als
doppelte Stimmgabel erlebt haben was
wohl vielleicht andere Studierende auch
über sie sagen
ich möchte Ihnen noch einige
Aussagen von unseren Studierenden
mitbringen wie beschreiben diese denn
prägende Dozierende bei uns am Sender
for advance studies und zwar habe ich
hier Aussagen und Statements von
Studierenden aus ganz unterschiedlichen
Befragungen sozusagen kondensiert und
zusammengefasst
sie können gerne einfach direkt einen
Blick darauf werfen ich lese es jetzt
gar nicht vor
ich möchte aber ein oton-zitat das
möchte ich Ihnen noch Vorlesen das sagte
ein Student diejenigen Dozenten waren
die besten die es als
Herzensangelegenheit gemacht haben und
das finde ich eine tolle Beschreibung
und was mir aufgefallen ist eigentlich
in diesen Statements ganz viel deckt
sich mit dem was Hartmut Rosa auch
überresonanz schreibt und was für mich
die gute Botschaft war dass unsere dass
unsere Studierenden sagen sie erleben
solche Dozierenden die sie nachhaltig
geprägt haben und wo sie wirklich auch
fürs Leben gelernt haben
ich weiß aber natürlich auch an unserer
Hochschule und an anderen Hochschulen
das ist auch noch ganz viele ungenutzte
resonanzschancen gibt und deshalb heute
auch mein Bett war je mehr Resonanz an
den Hochschulen
wie versuche ich persönlich
Resonanzräume zu öffnen und Resonanz
Erfahrungen zu fördern das möchte ich
Ihnen noch in einem letzten Schritt
vorstellen
zwei gut practices die sich in meiner
Lehrerfahrung das sind meistens Seminare
meistens auch Blockseminare mit bis zu
30 Studierenden was hat sich da bewährt
um die Studierenden sowohl miteinander
und mit mir in Resonanz zu bringen als
auch ein Resonanzraum für das Thema zu
schaffen
zum einen ist es ein bewusst gestalteter
check-in
also eine Methode oder eine Phase zu
Beginn wo alle die Möglichkeit haben
sich persönlich aber auch inhaltlich
sozusagen in die Veranstaltung
einzuchecken
der Mehrwert was da entsteht ist
kennenlernen also man lernt sich
gegenseitig kennen als ganze Personen
Aufbau von Vertrauen es werden die
persönlichen Anknüpfungspunkte zum Thema
geknüpft und jeder darf bzw muss schon
etwas sagen jeder ist aktiv mit dabei
wie mache ich das ganz praktisch ich
habe ein Seminar zum Thema
Personalentwicklung da gehe ich
beispielsweise im Rahmen des Check-Ins
in Vorleistung ich berichte wie in der
wertschätzende Erkundung zu Beginn über
meine besten entwicklungserfahrungen wo
kann ich am besten lernen wo habe ich
mich am besten weiterentwickelt so
stelle ich mich vor und dann lade ich
die Studierenden in Kleingruppen zum
Austausch ein dass sie sich über ihre
besten Erfahrungen Gedanken machen denn
diese reflektieren und einander
mitteilen vielleicht auch welche
Schlüssel für Entwicklungsprozesse sie
darin finden und erst dann stelle ich
die Agenda vor erst dann den wir
sozusagen in die eigentlichen Themen ein
für mich ist dieses Tool oder diese
Methode ein Schatz eben weil ich hier
als erste Stimmgabel der Ton angeben
kann oder auch als taktgeberin für ein
gutes Miteinander schaue indem ich
beispielsweise den Check-In eine
persönliche Note gibt und mich auch als
Person zeige
die kollegiale Beratung ist für mich ein
zweites Tool was ich bewährt hat das
heißt an Student bringt ein brennendes
Thema aus seinem Berufsalltag
beispielsweise oder aus dem Ehrenamt mit
und die anderen Studierenden sind in
kollegiale Berater hier erlebe ich immer
wieder den Mehrwert dass sie sich also
selbstwirksam erleben sie erleben sich
als Augenhöhe mit mir auf Augenhöhe mit
mir als Dozierenden Vertrauen und
kooperations wird gestärkt wie ich finde
in fast keiner anderen Übung und oft
mache ich so dass ich schon im Check-In
nach möglichen Themen und Stoff für die
kollegiale Beratung frag also was sind
echt Themen was sie gerade beschäftigen
was in offene Fragen wo bräuchten sie
Hilfe und Unterstützung
noch eine letzte Anmerkung und dann bin
ich auf der Zielgerade ich sehe die Zeit
rennt
das Tool an sich kann nichts ich mache
immer wieder die Erfahrung es kommt auf
die Haltung es kommt auf meine Haltung
an wie ich da bin in der facilitation
sagt mir hier so schön wir selbst es
sind das wichtigste Tool wir als Person
und natürlich Resonanz gibt es nicht als
Rezept auch hier ist es so dass diese
Tools natürlich keine Erfolgsgarantie
geben dass ich Resonanz dann auch
tatsächlich ereignet sondern das ist und
bleibt ein Abenteuer ob es dann
tatsächlich so weit kommt
und ich hoffe ich konnte ihnen ein Stück
weit Lust machen auf dieses Abenteuer
Resonanz
und sich weiter darauf einzulassen ich
glaube wir haben tatsächlich auch
Handlungsbedarf da dafür ich möchte mit
einem Zitat von Hartmut Rosa schließen
was er 2016 in Zeit Campus gesagt hat er
sagt die Realität ist vielleicht dass
die Universität zu einer
entfremdungszone wird Ziel müsste es
sein die Universität zu einem
Resonanzraum zu machen ich glaube
studieren gelingt nur da wo es gelingt
resonanzverhältnisse aufzubauen
und da möchte ich weiter mit aufbauen
helfen und ich habe gehört ich glaube
ganz viele von ihnen tun das genauso ich
bin gespannt jetzt was bei ihnen in
Resonanz gekommen ist in diesen Vortrag
freue mich auf eine
resonanze Austausch und Diskussion und
danke ganz herzlich für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit